[Music]
[Applause]
one of the earliest movers and adopters
of FTTH right across Europe has been
orange and I'm delighted to be joined by
the group CTO in manual Agana manual
thanks for talking to us here in
Amsterdam what was behind that early
commitment to fibre yeah you're right we
are a strong believer of fibre since
it's very beginning I would say we
launched actually the first commercial
trial in 2006 and after years of rnd so
beyond that there is a strong conviction
coming from R&D I would say that fiber
and FTTH is the most potential as it's a
must must potential less and is the most
powerful and most future proof I would
say access technology now you've been
putting in fiber all over your various
networks during that time what have been
some of the challenges that you've had
to overcome a lot of challenges
obviously I would say the first one is -
is regulatory obviously so we have to
get the regulatory frame which is
favoring investments this first second
we have to create it's extremely
important to create an ecosystem of
skills in each and every country where
we operate
skills around fiber because fiber is a
matter of skills as well of field
technicians for example which is much
for complex of a Fessenden Zen copper of
the tail and then obviously it's also
very important to convert the
home fast into real customers as soon as
we can so making early commercial
success is extremely important as well
yes and of course I think people are now
seeing finally that fiber is very much
the enabler of 5g all those things going
forward and of course within your role
in the industry you're also chairman of
ng MN one of the pipe you know one of
the main industry associations working
with 5g so you you've got a foot in both
camps really haven't you right so as an
geuman obviously we have seen and we
have said that we need fiber to enable
5g so in one way fiber and five G are
nuts opposite I would say they are
complementary each other absolutely and
and how do you think we're progressing
in Europe with with ftth generally what
I think that we get an increasing
comprehension and increasing
understanding and an adoption of CF
fiber I would say of FTTH by the
industry and by most of the operators in
Europe I think the deployment is
accelerating in Europe obviously we are
a torrent we are veneer but now even in
England even in Germany you know
operators are starting deploying fibre
or so really the adoption is decreasing
and I think that for the customers you
know they are more and more aware of
what is fiber what fiber is bringing
sources they are starting to ask for
fiber and thirst it was an exciting time
thank you very much for joining us thank
you
[Music]
you